what's going on guys this is rob and uh
a couple of announcements before we
start this video the first thing is that
for those of you guys who are part of
the uh facebook page facebook.com comics
explained i'm restructuring it and
reworking it from the ground up a lot of
you guys will notice a lot of the posts
are gone and that's because a lot of the
posts that were made on there were done
by links as opposed to
directly uploading the videos to
facebook it wasn't until i brought
gordon on board and then we started
working more with the facebook page that
we actually started uploading videos
directly so a lot of those links are
taken away which means a lot of those
video series on there are somewhat
incomplete i'm in the process or at
least myself and gordon are in the
process
of going through and completing all
those so you're gonna see a lot of
videos being uploaded uh in a really
short amount of time so don't panic i'm
not trying to spam you guys we're gonna
keep it reasonable so we're not blowing
up your facebook feed with like 50
videos a day or something stupid like
that the other part of this is i want to
put a bug
in your all's ear uh that i'm currently
working on a project that i think is
going to be
amazing i think you guys are absolutely
going to love it uh it's really going to
sort of elevate
the the kind of community that we have
in a way that we haven't really been
able to do before i don't want to drop
too many spoilers at the moment but it's
awesome i think you guys are going to
love it i know we're excited to do it
here over comics explained i'm very
hyped to see what it turns into
but uh but yeah with all that being said
guys i don't want to waste any more time
uh let's begin alright what's going on
guys this is rob and we are back to
covering hickman's avengers and new
avengers
and and this is gonna be kind of an
interesting story this is one of the
stories we did not cover the first time
around right we left this bit of a story
out which in hindsight seemed like a big
mistake
because there are two big things that
come out of this story that go forward
into the future of hickman's avengers
and new avengers right two very very
very important things and we'll cross
that bridge when we get to it right and
once you guys
you guys will see one of them and you'll
recognize it right off the bat right if
you were part of our original videos
like you'll recognize it
right off the bat the other one might
take a little bit more poking around but
what this does here is this initially
picks up
in new york right with some what amounts
to like this giant crater in the ground
now of course you've got maria hill who
responds now for those of you guys who
are coming from the marvel cinematic
universe and you're aware of maria hill
but you don't know how she became
director of shield
she's been that way for quite some time
she really kind of rose to prominence as
the director of shield during the events
of civil war now there were some things
that led up to that uh and originally it
was nick fury but maria hill's been
director
for quite some time and the reality is
she's probably the most hated director
now she's been the director
really from from the events of civil war
running all the way up until the modern
era
and it wasn't really even directly civil
war it kind of was civil war
and then tony stark basically ended up
more or less winning quote-unquote the
civil war conflict for lack of a better
word and that led to him becoming
director of shield and then when he was
more or less forced out
and the whole thing was disbanded then
it was reformed under under norman
osborne the green goblin and then he was
defeated that led to the reinstatement
of maria hill as a director of shield
but basically what what this means here
is that she's kind of been running
shield for quite some time during civil
war she was hated right
like i hated her i was like dude she's a
terrible person right but it was cool
to for marvel to be able to write her in
such a way to where you know i had like
a i had an extremely emotional reaction
to her character in the sense of like
disdain right like it was just great
writing on behalf of marvel uh but the
reason why they're here is because of
course there's this massive crater
you've got shield agents who are on site
basically responding to it and
essentially telling her hey like we
called you here for a particular reason
and that's because the body of hank pym
was found here right the body of ant-man
was found at this location so what we
end up doing here is kind of jumping
back by four hours and picking up with
aim island now
aim is an organization we've talked
about before but we haven't really gone
super in depth so aim stands for
advanced idea mechanics and this
is an organization that was originally
part of hydra right so hydra was
basically formed by baron von strucker
with a little bit of a throw in from the
hand
in a in japan aim was a scientific arm
of hydra right where hydra was kind of
like this over
arcing force aim with the ones who focus
on the science side and they had a whole
bunch of different
events over the course of the years
right aim for example they were the
first ones to tap into and create a
cosmic cube
advanced idea mechanics have some pretty
notable roles but what's happening here
is they've basically managed to capture
a kind of artifact right to pull an
artifact through their their
you know technological device right
their portal more or less and the whole
thing is being watched over by minister
superior now superior is an old school
character when i say old school i mean
relative right she was created in the
captain america comics in 1991
originally she was a character who was
who formed a group called the famazons
right the idea was that she wanted to
basically dominate all the men across
the world uh her her campaign was put to
an end
pretty fast right she wasn't really a
major villain she's never been a major
player
right but at the moment she's currently
the scientist supreme now the role of
scientists supreme in marvel comics
exists in a couple different forms
you've got the scientists supreme of aim
which is basically what they call their
leader and then you have your scientist
supreme of earth which is where this
kind of recognized as the best
scientific mind on earth
and it's usually recognized by a higher
power beyond the advanced idea mechanics
you know for example hank pym
was recognized as the scientist supreme
he's the scientific equivalent of doctor
strange basically
and so it's it's a it's kind of a cool
little thing it's important to
differentiate between those two things
so you don't get them confused but the
whole thing is being watched over by her
and this this whole kind of
portal this whole kind of device they
have is designed to basically reach into
alternate realities now the reason why
this matters is because the device
really only ever seems to encounter
beings in alternate realities when their
universe is ending right because
remember the incursions are happening
and so advanced idea mechanics is aware
of them they're aware of these
incursions and everything going on and
so this device that they use to pull
things in
is the same device that was used to pull
hyperion from his dying reality and so
with that happening with the the portal
basically being open
the device going in and basically
opening up and allowing beings to pass
through what we end up getting are what
initially look like
the classic avengers and it's kind of
crazy because if the device can reach
through space then it can reach through
time right because time and space are
the same thing right you can't you know
adjust
one without adjusting the other and so
it's kind of cool because this this kind
of group here is sort of looking at the
situation and it's kind of like okay
this is advanced idea mechanics like
this is kind of crazy and initially like
they kind of have a little bit of a
conversation of sorts and it's kind of
like okay like when advanced idea
mechanics reveals like hey you're on
aim island then like it almost kind of
breaks out into a bit of a skirmish and
in fact the hulk almost begins to launch
an attack against them but then he's
basically told to stand down by the
avengers which he ultimately does they
go back into the portal and then they
basically leave but the funny thing
about this is they don't teleport back
to their universe
instead they end up elsewhere in the
main marvel universe they end up in new
york and so of course you've got ant-man
you've got thor you've got hulk you've
got
pretty much the classic avengers roster
as we knew them right this is the
original not really the original this is
avengers number four going forward and
the reason why i say avengers number
four is because that's where you ended
up having the discovery of captain
america the only person that's that's
major and absent here i would say is
probably neymar the submariner the cool
thing is that they kind of hearken back
to their own reality and basically
realizing that like that universe was
coming to an end between what they were
told by advanced idea mechanics and
between what they've kind of figured out
here or at least recalled in so far as
like when basically an incursion was
about to take place
and their universe was about to be
destroyed that the portal opened up and
they were basically kind of yanked
through but they ended up
basically jumping through to save
themselves as they start to make their
way around
thor looks a lot more nefarious right
and he kind of looks at these people
around here and it's like why are you
not kneeling before me well if you're
not going to kneel then that's fine let
me give you a taste of what it means to
be a god and uses this power
and kills people and it's kind of like
okay like this is a little bit bonkers
right so
jump back to the present moment right
now you've got maria hill who's
basically there in in shield
headquarters or at least shield
scientific base she's talking to the
avengers and she asked the question like
where were you three hours ago right
like what were you doing
three hours ago and the reason why that
question is being asked is because as
soon as this whole event takes place
right as soon as all this goes down you
basically have uh you know
advanced idea mechanics that kind of
hits the panic button now this is just
kind of a brief
jump back we're not going to stay in
this this one month ago period right so
don't really focus on the fact of this a
month ago but what this basically shows
us is that at some point in the past
advanced idea mechanics had discovered
the avengers in the midst of them
basically recovering from
a massive incident right this looks like
one of the big catastrophes on earth has
taken place during the event so far but
they end up sampling dna
from these from from like black widow
and thor hyperion they're basically
going through and and siphoning off
siphoning off dna samples from these
various guys right and so pick up a week
after that and you basically have them
kind of synthesizing the dna analyzing
the dna
and then you know basically two weeks
after that you've got advanced idea
mechanics doing what they usually always
do
creating super adaptoids now the reason
why this matters is because super
adaptoids are originally an advanced
idea mechanics creation and they're
exactly what they sound like they're
beings that are designed to adapt to
to various superheroes try to take on
their powers to take on their abilities
and so on and so forth and in fact the
super adaptoid itself which was the
first iteration of that character and
kind of went by his namesake was
probably one of the most capable
villains the avengers
ever faced right because he basically
had all their powers he could adapt to
all of their abilities and that's kind
of what what seemed to happen here right
and so jumping back to about three hours
ago where
we pick up with these avengers from this
this alternate reality having laid waste
to the entirety of new york the reason
why these super adapt toys being created
by advanced idea mechanics matter
is because this is cleanup duty they
don't want anybody to know that they
brought these individuals here
and so they basically dispatched the
super adaptoids to face off against
these avengers and for the most part the
super adaptoids are completely almost
completely and totally overwhelmed the
difference here is that the super
adaptoids were programmed to basically
subdue the avengers and bring them in
now one of the other things that goes on
here is that you've got you've got bruce
banner you got the controller that's
being used by wasp uh and basically like
when it's destroyed the incredible hulk
reverts back into bruce spanner that
matters we'll talk about that here in a
minute but
one of the super adaptoids begins to
basically kind of violate his own
programming
that instead of bringing in hank pym the
super adaptoid actually kills him but
the death of hank pym
this is one of the single most important
things to happen in this comic
and this is one of the things that you
kind of get into when it's jonathan
hickman tying into everything else right
but the long and short of this
is that's where the body of hank pym
comes from that the avengers basically
managed to get away and that the super
adaptoids are recalled by
uh by advanced idea mechanics and so the
the whole attempt to basically capture
the avengers it's considered to be a
failure and so what this does is it
picks back up in the in the current
moment right now
with the proper avengers right the the
avengers that we all know
being questioned by maria hill and
basically saying like three hours ago
like black widow was getting her nails
done
and carol danvers was working out thor
was drinking iron man's like i was
getting my nails done
but basically captain america is like
whatever it is that you believe you have
going on didn't have anything to do with
us
enter hyperion basically using his
superman-esque powers more or less
analyzing the body of hank pym
and coming to the realization that's not
our hank pym that's a hank pym from a
different universe i don't know what the
deal is with this guy but he's not from
here
and that kind of goes into the
investigation of the avengers trying to
figure out who these other avengers are
now what this does is it basically leads
to this revelation that we're all the
avengers from the alternate reality
left and they basically went to a
different location not not back to their
reality but they went back to a
different location
this leads to the discovery that bruce
banner from that alternate reality
avengers has actually made his way to
where the main marvel universe bruce
banner apartment resides and when he
gets there of course he finds bruce
banner from the main marvel universe so
you've got these two versions of bruce
who are basically encountering each
other now the follow-up to this
is that where the super adaptoids are
put back into their stasis cells that
the one who killed hank pym
basically begins to think for itself and
that's not how they're supposed to work
right the super adaptoids are programmed
for a particular cause they're
programmed for a particular action and
they're not supposed to be able to
deviate beyond that particular action
but this version basically becoming
self-aware and almost kind of becoming
sentient and essentially indeed becoming
sentient leads to it actually modifying
the other super adaptoids
these beings were originally created for
the purpose of exploring the multiverse
that was a whole idea behind
advanced idea mechanics designing them
the way that they work but what ended up
happening here is that with them
basically being sent after the uh the
avengers it basically seemed to be the
catalyst for why it is that like this
one adaptoid managed to break away from
its programming it was being tasked to
do something that it wasn't originally
programmed to do albeit its programming
was was still intact it was basically
just told on your way to exploring the
multiverse
take those guys out instead right it was
aim hitting the panic button but this
one small change
allowed it to begin deviating even
further away from its programming and so
what it does here is we basically jump
back to these two bruces talking to each
other right and we'll basically say
bruce one and bruce two because what you
get here
is this kind of explanation to a degree
right this sense that you you have uh
basically you know what we'll say bruce
ii is the one from the alternate reality
and bruce one is the the main marble
universe bruce and bruce two basically
reveals that that where bruce one can
kind of you know he turns into the
incredible hulk whenever he gets angry
bruce two basically says it used to be
that way but the avengers on his world
effectively lobotomized him and he
doesn't really have any access to the
emotional centers of his brain the only
time he becomes the incredible hulk is
when the circuitry inside his brain that
was implanted there by the avengers is
remotely activated using that remote
control
and they can basically turn him into the
incredible hulk any time they want to
and it's one of these things where
they're basically shown to be bad guys
that these guys are basically
you know bad avengers right because what
it does is it leads to the main marvel
universe avengers ultimately tracking
down these alternate reality avengers
and then of course
a great big huge fight breaks out and so
it's kind of nuts because where
iron man is facing off against this
alternate reality iron man tony stark is
kind of like okay like for this
alternate reality version it's like
you're a stark are you the sun
or something like that and and the
response of tony is yeah i mean i'm i'm
i'm the sun but like who are you like
what's your deal and this guy basically
reveals that he's jarvis he takes the
helmet off and says like i killed you as
soon as i got the chance like i killed
your father after he built the the
machine
you know and then i smothered you in
your crib right and then i took your
iron man tech and
of course that leads to tony stark
freaking out and attacking him for
captain america he's a villain in the
sense that like he's a general right and
he's just a nefarious guy right he
doesn't really have any any any
particular powers he's still kind of
captain america the way that he always
was
but like he's he's just a villain from
there you also have the alternate
universe version of thor and of course
it's kind of one of these funny things
because initially he holds off on
fighting the main marvel universe thor
and he's like hey man we can be friends
right like we can team up and we can
basically conquer this world together
and the response to the main marvel
universe thor is of what good are you if
you can't watch your backside which of
course leads to hyperion swooping in and
defeating the evil version of thor now
when the
hammer falls you end up seeing that it
says thor with two r's and it basically
says whosoever lifts this hammer or
holds this hammer
if they be unworthy shall possess the
power of thor that'll become important
later on if you are familiar with that
do not spoil please for the love of god
please for the love of god do not spoil
for the people who have no idea what
that means
and so of course you basically ended up
having uh one of the bruce banners who
was subdued by the other and then the
incredible hulk popping up here
now the fact that the controller was
destroyed and the fact that we're
basically dealing with you know this
this incredible hulk here really points
to the idea that it's the main marvel
universe bruce banner right
that's that's basically who this is like
the good guy bruce spanner but the cool
thing is that he kind of shows up here
and basically
allies himself with the evil avengers
now this leads to advanced idea
mechanics
firing what's called a a tachyon cell
which basically
encases the entirety of both avengers
teams and then freezes time inside
right so for them inside this bubble
time is completely frozen the important
thing is that once
advanced id mechanics goes in and then
once they get out everything will start
to return to normal and so they
basically grab the avengers abscond with
them and then take off
while that's happening these super
adaptoids basically open the portal that
accesses the multiverse and
walk through and basically walk through
to fulfill their purpose and to chart
the multiverse and so from there
we pick up with this this last little
tidbit of the story and we have bruce
banner who goes walking into stark tower
and basically starts having a
conversation
with uh with iron man this takes place
before the fight between both avengers
teams right so it's kind of this little
intermediary period as soon as that
version of bruce is defeated by the
maine marvel universe bruce banner he
dons his outfit takes his briefcase and
then walks to go see tony stark and as
he starts talking to tony it's one of
these things where he's kind of like
bruce banner knows something and tony's
kind of
kind of trying to catch up with what
bruce banner knows now the funny thing
about this is the way that tony plays it
tony stark does not like to look like he
doesn't know what's going on in the room
right he likes to be the guy who feels
like he's got it all figured out that's
the engineer in him the narcissist
that's the arrogant part of tony stark
that wants to believe he's the only one
that really has it all figured out or if
other people have it figured out he's
following right along with them but he
basically starts talking to tony about
like this this whole program right this
avengers initiative that they have
in effect created right this whole
avengers initiative program that's been
launched by them and the question is
with everything that's been going on
with this this you know advanced idea
mechanics retrieval unit grabbing that
avengers team and then whisking them
away and all that kind of stuff with
everything that's happening with regards
to all these events what bruce banner's
been doing
as bruce banner has been thinking when
bruce basically went alongside the
avengers and then snuck off
and then basically you know talk to
advanced idea mechanics to understand
what's going on that what advanced idea
mechanics revealed to this version of
bruce because he's like hey i was the
hulk of the time i'm regular bruce now
what's going on you know and he
basically says well i mean if you really
want to know like what we understand at
this moment
is it like the multiverse is dying every
every universe like what you have out
there in the multiverse
is you have earth that are crashing into
each other and if both earths make
contact
then both multiverses or both universes
are destroyed if one of the earth is
destroyed
the universes pass through each other
right and so these like you know
advanced idea mechanics is like from
from what we gather
that's what's happening and what we're
doing is we're basically just trying to
explore we're trying to understand it
and so that's when you basically turn
into the hulk
started freaking out and destroying
everything and then of course he shows
up here at the office of tony stark and
what he basically says
is like after learning that from
advanced idea mechanics after learning
all of that
i've started thinking i've started
realizing that it's some of the most
pivotal
events that we've been to the events
where like we were fighting the builders
in space that you weren't there that
reed richards wasn't there that black
panther wasn't there that doctor strange
wasn't there like like a lot of these
these guys that i know are not there so
my question
is why did you build the avengers team
and what's actually going on is the
multiverse actually dying and initially
like tony stark starts to dodge the
question right he tries to like avoid
the question dodge the question you know
and he starts he starts saying like
you're building this big dyson sphere
around the sun
except like when i was there it's
obvious from the design that you have
that you have no intention of finishing
it so you're using it for a very
particular purpose but you're not going
to weaponize the sun
and even if you could it's not going to
do anything so my question is
what's the point of all this what's
actually going on and that's when he
kind of starts to sort of assemble
everything together and say it's
actually real isn't it the multiverse is
actually collapsing and then
stark again kind of tries to dodge it
and that's when bruce banner corners him
and says you did it didn't you you
reformed the illuminati and the
responsive of of tony stark is
yes and then bruce starts injecting
himself with tranquilizers now the
tranquilizers aren't necessarily
designed to like put him to sleep
they're designed to keep the hulk from
manifesting because the more that bruce
is hearing the more pissed off he's
getting because he knows just like
we know as the reader the reformation of
the illuminati is never a good thing
it's always a bad thing when that
happens because it always leads to
problems
and so bruce starts asking like what
have you guys done up to this point have
you guys actually destroyed worlds yet
is that why you guys are building
weapons and the response of tony is
this is about as real as it gets man
like it's not some alien invading force
that we can fight off and and live
another day that's not how this works
these are earths that are showing up and
if they crash into hours after an
eight-hour window passes
our entire universe is destroyed there's
nowhere to run now the reality is that
there is and that's one of the things
that black swan talked about is that
there are realities there are universes
out there where the superheroes of earth
bailed on that universe they basically
opened a portal to a different dimension
and then took off and they left that
earth to die along with everybody with
it and then took off to an alternate
reality sometimes they encountered
worlds where there were superheroes
sometimes they encountered worlds where
there were no superheroes that was the
case with the evil avengers that showed
up from the alternate reality that
advanced idea mechanics brought in they
were sent to a different world where
there were no avengers they would just
kind of
jump into a new world and then literally
it's just jumping
jumping and sinking ship that's what
it's called it's considered to be a
cowardly thing to do but there are
people out there who did it there are
other instances in other realities where
superheroes on earth actually destroyed
their own planet to keep the
keep the the universe from dying and
then took up residence on a different
planet inside the universe right so
there's been different people who have
reacted in different ways
but the the question of bruce banner is
what's going on with your real plans
what have you done you know and and
that's where tony basically says we
haven't really destroyed a world yet we
haven't had to at least we haven't
destroyed and inhabited earth yet we
have not been met with an earth that has
superheroes and has human beings living
on
living on it that we've actually
destroyed we've been lucky but the
reality is
if it comes to that i don't know if
that's something that i'm that i'm able
to do and the response of tony and
saying that and saying like i don't
really know if it's something that i am
or am not willing to do means he's
preparing himself to do that and that's
the reality of it is that time is going
to come when they're going to have to
destroy an inhabited world
in order to save their own and so with
bruce basically realizing this that's
when he starts to get angry and that's
when he starts to freak out he says what
am i supposed to do with this
like what am i supposed to do with this
information am i supposed to keep it to
myself the fact that the multiverse is
basically dying that like the potential
is going to be there for you guys to
destroy an inhabited world with
billions of innocent lives to save our
own is that something that i'm supposed
to be okay with like do i hide this from
steve rogers do i hide this from
from like betty ross you know or like
thunderbolt ross do i hide this from
people
you know do i keep this to myself and so
what this does is it basically leads to
this this alternate reality bruce banner
basically you know kind of showing up
here or at least being met by tony stark
and and what tony end up ends up doing
is basically saying hey look uh you know
banner's pumped full of tranquilizers
you know we got to kind of keep things
we got to keep them on ice until things
are okay tony attaches a
device to the back of his neck that
basically keeps him from being able to
talk
and so this bruce is just kind of more
or less hidden away right he's basically
just taken away
and locked in a cell where he could
never become the incredible hulk again
and that's where this whole thing dead
ends into the necropolis now the
acropolis as most of you guys probably
know from the previous videos is the
wakandan city of the dead right that
during jonathan hickman's fantastic four
run
because of the story doom war basically
showing that t'challa
lost the role of black panther to his
sister shuri
you know he was basically just a guy who
was there and so when he went to visit
the panther god bass bass basically gave
him dominion over the dead right
this ability to communicate and talk to
the dead and so with this place
basically being an insane and
exceedingly
sacred location no one's allowed here
except for t'challa he's the only person
that can get in here because he's the
only person that needs to be here he's
the only person that can talk to the
dead i mean i guess sure he can do it
too but it's one of these kind of
respectful things but she kind of
maintains that level of respect but the
reason why that matters is because what
this means is that the evil version of
bruce is basically locked away he's hid
away this allows for
bruce banner in the main marvel universe
for tony stark to pass that alternate
reality version off of
bruce as the main marvel universe bruce
so as far as everybody out there is
aware
bruce banner's sitting in a prison cell
it means that he can now operate in
secret without anybody actually knowing
what he's doing and that's exceedingly
important
because he's now being introduced and
being brought into as part of the
illuminati and so from there we switch
over to the second epilogue here and
this is probably one of the most
important parts of the story and the
reason why is because as these super
adaptoids are cruising through the
multiverse they end up discovering this
kind of
space station more or less that exists
between universes and what this does is
it basically has them landing on its
location
and when they get there they're met by
what are basically map makers
and that's where the kind of questions
asked by these map makers do you know
what you are like
what was your what was your purpose you
know and they say well our purpose was
was to explore right that was the entire
basis behind us then the the map makers
like but you've surpassed your creator's
intentions haven't you and the response
is
yes you know and and so ultimately you
know when when the question's asked you
know what are you the adaptoid responds
i'm an explorer and the map maker
responds no
you're a map maker this is where the map
makers come from right the map makers
basically originate and we'll find out
more in terms of where the original map
makers came from and how it is they kind
of propagate themselves this way but the
the quick answer here
is that map makers come into existence
when a form of artificial intelligence
basically reaches sentience right when
it reaches a super high level of
intelligence but there's a reason why
that happens
it's not simply just because of the fact
that this one particular super adapter
managed to break away from its
programming there's also something else
at play here but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you